hey good humans jason from jubilee here
at the jubilee office i just want to
take a moment to say thank you to
the ridge wallet for sponsoring this
episode
i honestly just got this wallet and i
think it's incredible
i think it looks super dope really
really sleek
super thin and also really really
durable it's amazing and it has a full
lifetime
warranty
it can hold up to 12 cards which is a
big concern sometimes i have with
thin wallets and has space for your cash
as well
i highly recommend it i've loved
carrying it around they've got over 30
different options for colors
uh you can have carbon fiber burnt
titanium i honestly love it so much i
might get a second one just so i can
kind of switch up
the colorways there's also even a 45-day
guarantee
so if you get it and you don't love it
you can always send them back for a full
refund so there is no risk
if you use our code jubilee you actually
get 10 off make sure you check them out
and with father's day around the corner
and this could be the perfect gift for
your father
or honestly yourself or your mother
anyone really
make sure you check out regular thank
you again for the sponsorship and we
hope you enjoy this episode
there's been times where i tried dating
people
because everyone is doing it but i was
always up front like hey i'm asexual
this might not be your thing you know
and then they're like no no i
totally understand three months later
they're having a tantrum because you
won't kiss him
even though i'm asexual i still
experience attraction three
two one go
wait no i did it wrong i'm sorry no i
didn't i'm sorry
i'm sorry to the class like there have
been times in my life where i've been
like
is this attraction or like is is
something happening here
but for the most part i have just been
like
no like that person is nice looking but
i don't feel any sort of thing
asexuality it really is a large spectrum
under the spectrum i fall under
demisexual which basically
means that i need a strong emotional
bond with someone before i could feel
any type of sexual attraction i can look
at someone and say this person is really
attractive
but you know i don't have sexual
attraction
or like i want to date this person
there's also um
like different forms of attraction i can
be attracted to aesthetics but i don't
really have like a romantic attraction
i masturbate on a regular basis
three two one go
let's see here i mean i guess i'll go
first
the way that i've been able to find a
lot of people like in the ace community
is through the kink community and so
usually when i am masturbating it's
things
kink related and so yeah i do masturbate
on a regular basis
but it's never in the sense that i'm
like craving sex or one sense or even
buying sex attractive i don't feel like
horny often so like when it does happen
i was like okay
i think it's scientifically it's just
like i need to really i just need to
relieve myself
got to do something about it yeah do
something about it yeah it just seems so
time consuming
to do regularly like i mean
i got tv shows i could watch i don't
know
i just feel like there's no need for it
you know i'm really contemplating myself
like if i have an urge i can eat
personally like when i get an urge it's
more of an annoyance for me
asexual people like just because they
don't experience attraction doesn't mean
that they don't have any libido
exactly and so like you still might feel
the the need for that sometimes but like
i feel like for a lot of aces it's just
like oh this again yeah it's kind of
like
attached it it kind of is like a chore
that you're
all right with doing but there's not
really much of a payoff for getting it
done
i'm curious to hear like your guys's
thoughts on like
someone like me who's on the opposite
side of the spectrum
like how do you view that as an ace
well i mean high libido doesn't mean
attraction
it's they're completely different things
like i don't get it
but i respect it
i find sex repulsive
three two one go
for me at least it's just like there's
always a bunch of other ways of
attraction because like at the end of
the day it doesn't have to be sexual in
nature you can find it
with like other just like other things
whether it's aesthetic or otherwise
i'm in like the gray spectrum of it of
like asexuality so like there are days
where i want like there are days i feel
it
there like times where i do there's
times i don't
[Laughter]
some people communicate through sex like
that's their way of showing their
emotion and though
it may not be for me it just depends on
who the person is because you're
supposed to be able to trust that person
as well so if you don't trust them
like what good is that going to do for
you you know and i really do feel like
sex
for me as a demisexual it's um
like if we're not connected on an
emotional or intellectual level
i just don't want it i'm not repulsed by
other people doing it like anyone can do
what they want
obviously it's not something i can see
myself participating in asexuality is
purely about the attraction and not
about
the action you know you can not
experience that attraction
and still be like oh this feels nice to
me like
sex is like an activity that you do in
the same way that you can like
hug someone or shake their hand like for
me it doesn't have like
some other level or like the the level
that society wants to tell you that is
inherent to sex like i'm just like no
it's
it's an activity that you do with one or
more other people like that's
all it is exactly
i am a virgin
three two one
go
wow that's kind of what i expected
for me like sex isn't like people always
talk about it and then it's just like
well that's not really attractive to me
and i have a supportive friend group i
have hobbies i can do and it's like
i'd rather find my time doing something
else there's been times where i tried
dating people because everyone is doing
it
but i was always up front like hey i'm
asexual this might not be your thing
you know and then they're like no no i
totally understand
three months later they're having a
tantrum because you won't kiss them i've
been in a couple relationships before
both with men and a woman and so yeah
i've had sex with both
of my partners so yeah i'm
not when when did you lose your
virginity
i lost my virginity when i was
15 or 16. what about you i was
i was 17 when i lost mine and
it's not the greatest story i
i was coerced into having sex
by my um by my girlfriend at the time uh
uh okay um so i lost
my virginity um well because uh
it was if you loved me then you'd have
sex with me and at the time i was like
okay this is my first relationship
and i don't wanna i don't have to feel i
don't wanna have sex with her but
i'm scared that she might break up with
me because i don't wanna have sex with
her
so yeah and that's that's a really
strong thing
it's the one so of course you'd want to
make sure you'd stay with them
i want to hug you i know
you support you i commend you for you
know having gone through that
and being able to still you know find
yourself and be who you are today
and i want to hug you but i don't know
if i can
thank you so i mean me personally i've
never
experienced any of it i don't wish that
i could
experience sex there's moments where i
wish i wasn't asexual
i'm just gonna start crying too it's
like it's so ingrained
in our society that you should have
attraction you should have a romantic
attraction you should have sexual
attraction
so a lot of us if we don't have the word
we feel
so broken until we find it i was so
lucky because i had a parent who knew
what the word was
and like my mom actually said maybe
you're asexual you don't
feel those things and that's okay but so
many people
don't have that word
i feel invisible to the lgbtq plus
community
three two one go
the lgbt community of itself is very
sexualized
like at pride it's it's very sexual
i think it's hard for them to include
the sexuality that is absence of that
i've heard so many people say that
asexuals
don't get as oppressed as other people
in the lgbt community
but that's not all that lgbt community
is
it's not just whether you'd get
oppressed or kicked out by your family
we're still experiencing things
differently from the rest of the world
and
it feels better to have a community of
people
for me this question is a little bit
personal because
the closest thing was for me was my
auntie because my auntie is lesbian
and it comes to relation with family
like everyone accepts my auntie
but when it comes to me it's just like
oh you don't exist
you haven't tried it yet it makes me
feel a little bit empty because like
you're my family you're supposed to like
you're supposed to be with me like
you're supposed to be able to comfort me
like as you say like pride is really
sexualized and like being sex positive
and
look encouraging people to have as much
sex as they want also means that
sometimes they don't want any
i've heard people say like like what you
experience is valid
but you're not queer enough to be in the
community and i'm like
then what is queer enough as someone who
identifies as gay i really did want to
hear
everything out that they were saying
because i completely agree with
everything that they just said i do see
more things on social media like i was
just on the lgbt
website and they list like a whole list
of different um
ace identities we are becoming a little
bit more open-minded about it
but i don't want to give too much credit
because i 100
agree that we need a lot of work in the
community the increased visibility is
great it's really good
but it also is driven by
ace people and aspects and there's no
one
at least there are fewer people in the
broader queer community who are reaching
out to us
and being like we want you involved i do
know some
people like they kind of just feel like
they don't belong
in the community so they just stick to
basically an ace community
and i mean i don't know about you but
when i went to like
meetups and stuff i would ask if
asexuals were welcome
so i guess where i find community it's
definitely like the internet because
like
i definitely remember watching like this
show called like bojack horseman and
when you when i found out that like one
of the main characters todd was
like an asexual himself i was like oh
wow
here's like someone in actual media
space that like i can actually relate to
at the end of the day
and he wasn't treated as like a fix-it
case that's like the biggest thing
is that if there's an asexual in media
they're just broken yeah we really find
community
through the internet i've not been with
this many aspects ever in my life
i am still exploring my sexuality
three two one go
i used to identify as demi and then i
went to ace like grace
so like i'm still like is this correctly
what i identify as i am
still unsure of myself like i don't know
what my own feelings are
half the time and i am still young
so i'm trying to be okay
with not really knowing some things
about myself
at least for now i think i have a pretty
down pat
and i think that's one of the
misconceptions about the ace community
is that people will approach you and
will think that you're
not um experienced or you don't know
what you're looking for
or you're too young and you'll figure it
out um and that's
very um wrong especially in my case like
i feel like i'm really well experienced
and i do know what i like and i do know
what i don't like
um but at the same time i think that
there is still some exploring that i am
doing
like for me it's like i i'm in the
disagree
section because like i feel pretty like
i'm pretty solid in my identity
there are times where i'm like is was
that attraction what was that
but like it doesn't matter what it was
like it's not gonna change my behavior
i feel like at this point i already know
what i want
and i'm so over like other people
judging me for it
you know i'm just going to stay here in
my little bubble i'm comfortable
being right here you know i've
had the term since i was like 10. i'm
sure my mom probably thought i would
grow out of it i'm sure she thought i
was a light bloomer or something
but like as i got older it's just like
it just
it just kept fitting i had an experience
where i found the term when i was 11
12. so when i first
heard that when i first found out about
what even sexuality is
i found asex when i was like okay i'm
asexual but then
when i got to high school i was like you
can be straight or something like
everyone else around you straight yeah
and then i was like okay no maybe i'm
gay because i'm not straight
then i got to college i'm like okay
maybe i'm bi maybe
i like them
and only like in the last couple months
i was like i finally went back to
asexual it's a broad label and i can be
comfortable
being under that umbrella yeah
we have to like exchange instagrams yeah